messieurs
alors on en parlera un petit peu plus
tard mais il faut dire que c'est un des
costumes de votre spectacle tu as fait
j'ai complètement repositionné mon image
je suis assez surpris le conseiller en
communication de robert hue
il a dit avec ça normalement tu vas
pouvoir refaire des émissions
culturelles
[Applaudissements]
mais en tous les cas de l'histoire est
en train de vous donner raison parce que
j'ai vu cette semaine la une du figaro
qui expliquait finalement que c'est pour
diversifier leur approvisionnement en
pétrole que les états unis de george
bush voulait attaquer l'irak donc voilà
donc ça veut dire que vous vous disiez
ça il ya quelques mois tout le monde
vous tomber dessus et puis maintenant
l'histoire vous donne raison je vous
remercie vous vous étiez le seul à
pouvoir m'a vite et encore dans une
émission de télé sillage c'est que tout
le monde peut dire ce qu'il a à dire
même si je suis pas toujours d'accord
les gens peuvent parler voilà donc c'est
assez appréciable parce que ça a été
assez le boycott généralisé donc la
bomba ça fait plaisir merci donc
l'histoire vous donne raison d'une
certaine façon ben oui on voit enfin on
voit aujourd'hui chaque jour cette
arrogance américaines continueront pas
le peuple américain est otage de ceux de
ce pouvoir mais oui bien précisé qu'on
peut être anti bush sans être anti
américains sur la scène mais encore
faut-il le dire parce que les amalgames
sont vite fait comme on peut ne pas
apprécier sharon et ne pas être
antisémite voilà par exemple est ce que
j'ai une gueule d'antisémite
sont très très très anti sharon ouais
ouais vraiment très anti char alors
aujourd'hui vous êtes d'accord avec
jacques chirac finalement dieudonné
ouais ouais moi je trouve qu'il faut que
je trouve que il a eu une attitude assez
oui mais son refus si je pense qu'il n'y
ait plus d'ambiguïtés dans sa position
que dans celle du chancelier allemand
chancelier allemand sous la pression des
verts d'ailleurs notamment de fisher a
dit de manière très claire il n'y aura
nous sommes contre une intervention
américaine en irak y compris avec le feu
vert de l'onu way or la chiraquie ne dit
pas tout à fait la même chose et en plus
à l'assemblée nationale il accepte que
l'on ait un débat sur l'irak mais il a
recommandé au président de l'assemblée
nationale que ce ne soit pas sanctionné
par un vote moi je n'accepterai pas je
trouve que de la même manière que
l'envoyé troupes en afghanistan sans
être consultés je ne vois pas au nom de
quoi l'exécutif pour envoyer les troupes
françaises en irak sans que la
représentation nationale soit consulté
je pense que sa position est ambiguë à
dieudonné donc maintenant tout le monde
est d'accord avec vous sa voiture un
vrai bonheur c'est enfin très clair non
français pour avoir dit ce qu'on est en
train de berlin ça a été un petit peu je
me suis prononcé contre la guerre
américaine en afghanistan et j'ai été
très sévèrement
critiqué parce que j'ai dit que c'était
une guerre contre le peuple afghan je
maintiens que cette opération n'était
pas d'idée par les meilleures intentions
mais bush il a fait quelque chose de
très malin même si je pense que c'est un
monstre c'est qu'il a dit vous êtes avec
nous ou contre nous c'est à dire il a
transformé le monde en noir et blanc
c'est à dire on n'avait pas le droit
d'être pas forcément pro ben laden si on
était il fallait choisir comment mais
vraiment donc j'ai donné vos prises de
position au printemps dernier vous ont
amené à arrêter votre campagne
présidentielle
on regrette que vous n'ayez pas été
président parce que vous auriez sans
doute revaloriser le smic plutôt que les
salaires des ministres mais c'est clair
que j'avais quelques mesures à mettre en
place pour je pensais aussi que bon il y
avait un rapprochement possible au
second tour avec noël j'étais persuadé
qu'on arriverait peut-être en tête mais
bon ça c'est pas organisé de cette façon
là bon c'est pour ça que je pense que
c'est regrettable est que la classe
politique devrait accepter à la tribune
des libres penseurs parce que le vote
contestataire c'est le pen qu'il a pris
1 pour son compte et je pense qu'à
gauche il y avait possibilité aussi de
rassembler des gens qui ne se sont pas
mobilisés au premier tour ce qui fait
que le bourg et le pen n'aurait
peut-être pas été ce qu'on tourne alors
je devais si vous aviez été président
vous auriez interdit le front national
allez
moi je sais pas si j'aurai interdit le
front national
dont je pense pas que j'aurai un père
dit le front national bon je pense que
c'est une grosse bêtise que de dire
qu'il faut interdire le front national
ça me rappelle ce qu'avait dit bertold
brecht au aux allemands à la dictature
allemande en 53 lorsque le peuple
s'était soulevée il avait dit si vous
n'aimez pas le peuple changer de peuple
interdire le front national c'est non
seulement faire de le père d'une victime
qui s'empêcherait qui ce qui très vite
jours et là dessus et puis s'est
transformé en pestiféré les gens qui
votent pour lui donc le problème c'est
pas d'interdire le front national c'est
de faire que par exemple la gauche aille
vers ceux qui ont voté pour le front
national c'est qu'elle fasse une
politique de gauche dieudonné si vous
aviez été prise en mains publiques vous
auriez amnistié david douillet
c'est un grand champion comme moi j'ai
fait du judo pendant 15 ans 1 je dois
dire que c'est quand même un sacré
champion ps que vous auriez épouse et
bernadette chirac pour qu'elle reste la
première dame de france
je suis je suis marié j'ai une épouse
c'est vrai que bernadette a des
avantages aussi à ses charmes non mais
c'est clair que j'aurais pu me laisser
tenter là encore cela qu'on ne s'est pas
rencontrés mais je vous cache pas que il
ya un côté qu aucun mensonge
laissez là
tuez le si vous aviez été président est
ce que vous auriez favoriser le lobby
noir
non je suis ni blanc ni noir je suis je
suis un humain sur cette note je suis
contre les frontières quelle quelle
qu'elle soit ethnique religieuse
géographique national je me bats contre
les lobbys il en existe il en existe et
je trouve ça regrettable est ce que vous
vous seriez balader les couilles à l'air
au fort de brégançon
j'aurais fait plus fort
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater le il
a l'habitude abonnez vous y mettez un
peu de bleu